IRA rode in what's the wackiest office
or workplace drama you've experienced or
been around I've been around some pretty
crazy stuff II I I did work in retail
from about a junior year of high school
until freshman year of college at the
now-defunct Circuit City
I've been around every possible type of
workplace drama there were what we would
call bathroom bandits who seemed
obsessed with doing very very weird
things in the bathroom I'll sort of
leave it at that
and just trying to figure out like who
it was and it was incredibly dramatic
what III still I know we've been talking
about this for years and I remember once
when Lewis was still in the program he
believes that some people get off
sexually from doing really strange
things in bathrooms that you would say
why not just go in and use the bathroom
like a normal person and then leave
people who have to come up with you know
it's the equivalent of you know they
have the creativity of someone who could
invent the universe of narnia given the
the bizarre and and unique things that
they're doing in the bathroom why not
just go and use the bathroom Lewis
seemed convinced that some of these
people were sexually aroused by doing
strange things and bathrooms and using
using devices in other ways in which
they're not meant to be used so that was
a pretty big drama at Circuit City there
were a couple bathroom bandits that we
were trying to figure out like who on
earth is doing these things
I call them poopa traders the poopa
trader yeah right and that was that's
only part of it that's only part of it
also like romantic workplace drama who
hasn't been around that type of thing
there's been a lot of incidents like
that there were incidents so this this
was a crazy thing at Circuit City
one of the biggest dramas I remember and
I think it's okay to tell this now I
don't believe any of this was ever
publicly known and the the coho company
is bankrupt now and I'm not even gonna
say I'm not saying this happened at the
store I worked at there was a consortium
for a lack of a better term that worked
with an outsider and someone who worked
in the warehouse right and at Circuit
City you had the sales people who were
on the sales floor but if you sell a big
TV the TVs are in the back so when you
sell it the warehouse staff gets a
little printout or something that says
hey this product has been sold to grab
it and bring it out to the loading dock
products started to go missing expensive
products and management
could not figure out for the life of
them what was going on because they
didn't see on camera any products just
being stolen when nothing had been
purchased they didn't see any staffers
taking products and they figured out
that what was going on is a customer
would come in and they were working with
someone in the warehouse they knew when
their warehouse friend was working they
would come in and they would buy I don't
know a 20 inch flat panel monitor right
something that at the time was new it
wasn't super cheap but it was you know a
couple hundred bucks or whatever the
warehouse would get a printout saying
this monitor has been sold go ahead and
grab it and bring it out to the customer
at the loading dock they would go and
they might grab four monitors or they
might grab a monitor and an expensive
computer and then they would be seen
going out and putting the product into
the customers car and this tricked the
loss prevention people who started
investigating it because there were
never any warehouse people taking any
items themselves they would wait until a
product had been sold and they had to go
and grab it from the warehouse and they
would bring that product out to the car
of this so-called customer even though
the customer was again working in
cahoots with the warehouse person but
they would bring out extra stuff and at
the time the loss prevention technology
was not as good as it is now where it
would be as easy to tell that extra
product was being brought out so it took
many months for this to be figured out
eventually it was people were arrested
and it was pretty ugly until the circuit
said he ended up going bankrupt so yeah
I think that kind of gives you some
insight into huh well they made a number
of mistakes they made a number of
mistakes and they ultimately did go
bankrupt but those are those are some of
the biggest dramas that I remember you
know when I started working at the David
Pakman show it was really tough finding
parking around here because you know
we're in Boston
sometimes there's meters you can grab
one now sometimes it's just street
parking but it can be few and far
between to find these spots now here we
don't really have meters to close
no no it's mostly Park yeah and you know
I'm trying to make a good first
impression we're trying to be here right
on time but I'm having a really
difficult time finding a parking place
yep so I just parked right on the side
of the building right and you know the
assumption
is if there's no signs that say no
parking you're good only problem is the
street there isn't - too wide and
there's a bunch of trucks right across
the street that have to get in and out
they make some incredibly tight
maneuvers yeah so I pioneer a spot I'm
the first to park on the street I'm like
alright I got to get to work a guys
start working on the David Pakman show
for the first time yep I'm nervous as it
is and I see one of these truckers get
out of his vehicle and he says yeah
you're gonna leave that there for the
whole day and go yeah I got a bag I'm
working in the building next door I got
to leave this here and he goes you know
we have we have trucks we have to like
turn around the guys basically trying to
bully me into moving the car now he
never says you're not allowed to park
there because you are technically
allowed to park there
yeah because even if he did say that I
wasn't allowed to park there I'd be like
alright we'll go to the city and get a
sign then right this is your problem not
mine absolutely he was clearly just
trying to bully me out of it try to like
to move to somewhere else so you know I
understand like the trucks have to get
in and out that's not that's a hard job
to do but also I gotta get to work
myself absolutely and within a few days
it wasn't just me parking there it was a
whole line of cars so clearly that's
what they were trying to prevent all
along but I'm just the perfect person
that was able to break the system and I
feel like I pioneered a whole new spot I
feel like I left my mark on the David
Pakman show before ever even showing up
to the building can't you now not park
there though because everybody parks
there now yes
and I was destroyed my own creation now
I have to park somewhere else I have to
pioneer a new spot well there there
there I'm suspicious about what's going
on with the parking around the building
because there used to be another Street
nearby where you would always see people
parked and then all of a sudden there
were no cars there and we didn't really
know why and there's been one very small
no parking sign and apparently it
applies to about 500 feet of street or
something like that because no one parks
there in the last time I saw someone
parked there they had a ticket on their
car so it's very weird I don't really
get what's going on around here and
they're former intern actually followed
my lead and pioneered a new parking area
yeah and so I started parking there too
I was pretty proud of him for doing that
actually oh yeah it was probably
arguably in addition to his long-form
video production his biggest
contribution to the program during that
during because it was huge it was
life-altering and
and one time after the show I go back to
my car and I see a typed message on a
piece of paper that says please do not
park here trucks can't turn now I'm
going to ignore it until they get a sign
from the city but I am kind of worried
about my car being vandalized
I wouldn't yeah that's right I try
didn't know about that that's that's a
new revelation I have a real problem
with this it parking is so limited as it
is and because there's places that
trucks don't want you to park you're now
not allowed to park I completely reject
that and this is a huge office building
where people have to get to work
absolutely despicable